قطر اذا تستعد قبل ايام من استضافه نهايه
كاس العالم هنا وضيفنا ايضا يستعد
للمشاركه معنا في التغطيه الخاصه
بالمونديال يرحب به على الصوره محمد كتب
الصحفي الرياضي اهلا بك يا محمد مساء
الخير معاذ تحياتي لكم المشاهد الجزيره
ومحمد
على وصول الكاس الذهبيه الى قطر
سنبدا من هذا الخبر مجسم كاس العالم حتى
رحاله وفي الدوحه بعد انها زوجته العالميه
الترويجيه وذلك قبل ايام فقط من انطلاق
مونديال قطر 2002 و20 الكاس كانت قد بدات
جوله الترويجيه الخارجيه في اماره دبي قبل
نحو سته اشهر على انطلاق المنافسات وطافت
حول احدى و50 دوله واقليما خلال جوله
عالميا ما في ذلك جميع الدول اثنتين 32
التي تاهلت الى نهائيات كاس العالم قطر
فوتبول
الى هذه المنطقه لقد تنقلنا حول انحاء
العالم انا سعيد بذلك هناك جزء صغير من
قاره اسيا انا سعيد بان الاطفال سيرون كاس
العالم في هذه المنطقه ويمكنهم الذهاب الى
الملعب لقد تحدثنا كثيرا عن المونديال
وخططنا كثيرا لذلك
جيدا الكاس الذهبيه محمد لانه توج بها مع
فرنسا عام 98
الكاس ذات رمزيه ودلالات كبيره جدا لعشاق
كره القدم وحتى لمن لا يهتم بكوره القدم
يعني اشهر من كثير من اللاعبين هذه الكاس
فشل اي بطوله عالميه في كره القدم في ان
تحتل محل كاس العالم هذا الامر تثبته هذه
الجوله يثبته الاهتمام الاعلامي بوصول
النسخه الاصليه من كاس العالم الى قطر
بالنسبه لكل التحضيرات وكل همم يعني العمل
الذي استمر لسنوات
لاجلاب لجلب كاس العالم الى قطر هذا تتويج
له هذه اللحظه تاريخيه عندما يتحدث مرسيدس
سريعا قيمه كاس العالم هو رجل حمل كاس
العالم لكن حتى لمن لم يحضر اي مباراه في
كاس العالم وصول كاس العالم الى قطر
يمنحهم جوا الان انتهت حقبه الاهتمام
بالكره الاوروبيه وبكره الانديه وحانت
لحظه حمى المونديال
ربما هذا ايضا مؤشر على تسير على العدد
العكسي مع قدوم هذه الكاس الى قطر
هذه الكاس بجوله ترويجيه داخل قطر في
المعالم
الثقافيه المعالم الرياضيه الحضاريه في
قطر اذانا بعد ذلك بانطلاق هذا المحفل
الكروي الكبير ولحظه التاريخيه بالنسبه
لجماهير كره القدم القطريه هذه كاس العالم
اتت لي تقام البطوله على ارضهم وبحضور
الجماهير من مختلف انحاء العالم وعايز في
الساعات القليله الماضيه خلال وجودي في
الدوحه لمس وجود جماهير من بلدان العالم
البرازيل من الارجنتين شاهدت عائله
اكوادريه تتسوق بقمصان المنتخب الاكوادور
اسبوع قبل ضربه البدايه الى المنتخب
القطري شهاده جماهير من غانا من القاره
الافريقيه بدات في التوافق كل هذه
الجماهير عندما تحضر لحظه دخول كاس العالم
دخول كاس البطوله الى العاصمه القطريه
تبدا اجواء مختلفه تبدا الاستعداد الحقيقه
وكانها تستعد مثل اللاعبين
التفاعل هنا في قطر والتفاعل الخارجي ايضا
انه اضيء مبنى اللجنه القطريه لاعاده
اعمار غزه غرب مدينه غزه بشعار بطوله كاس
العالم قطر 2020 من المقرر ان تحيا اللجنه
القطريه الحدث المونديال تاريخي من خلال
بث المباريات وخاصه مباريات المنتخبات
العربيه عبر شاشات عملاقه في احدى القاعات
الرياضيه في مدينه همم غزه
لاني لاخر اخبار المنتخبات وصلت بعثه
المنتخب المغربي العاصمه القطريه الدوحه
منذ قليل تدشين المشاركه سادسه في تاريخ
نهايه كاس العالم لاسود الاطلس ضمت بعثه
المنتخب المغربي سبعه لاعبين فقط على انضم
اليهم باقي اللاعبين تباعا بعد انتهاء
التزاماتهم مع انديهم في الدوريات
الاوروبيه من المقرر ان تغادر البعثه الى
الامارات لخوض اخر مواجهه تجريبيه امام
جورجيا الخميس المقبل قبل العوده مجددا
لمقاري اقامتها في الدوحه يلعب منتخب
المغربي الاولى مباريات في المونديال امام
المنتخب الكرواتي وصيف النسخه السابقه في
الثالثه والعشرين من نوفمبر الحالي على
استاد البيت المونديالي
بالطبعا ايه فيما يتعلق بالمنتخب المغربي
محمد لا باس ان نشير الى خبر يمكن نصف
وهكذا بالمؤسف منذ قليل اصابه امين حارث
لاعب مارسيليا الفرنسي الذي كان مدعو
للمشاركه مع المغرب في المونديال الاصابه
مبدئيا تبدو خطيره
ومنطقيا اقول في انتظار ان شاء الله الامر
لا يكون هكذا قد تحرمه من المشاركه في كاس
العالم
ويبدو انه يتالم من ركبه اصابه الركبه
عاده تعرف معز تستغرق وقتها اطول من
الاسبوع الذي يتبقى على المونديال وربما
على المعسكر المغربي ان يبدا في التفكير
عن بديل امين حارث اذا ما اثبتت التقارير
الطبيه غياب هذا اللاعب عن كاس العالم
ضربه كبيره المنتخب المغربي اللاعب
بمهارات كبيره لاعب يقدم موسما لا باس به
مع اولمبيك مرسيدس وان لم يكن اسيا في
خيارات المدرب لكن كان سيكون له كبير
مقصوده نتمنى ان يكون الامر كما كان مع
ساديو ماني مثلا همم التي تكون الاصابه
خطيره ويلحق بشكل او باخر على الاقل ليس
في المباراه الاولى الثانيه الثالثه ما
الى ذلك اعلن جون هيرتمان قائمه المنتخب
الكندي الذي يستعيد واخر لخوض غماري كاس
العالم قطر 2022 سديس نجم بايرن ميونخ
الالمانيه على التشكيله التي ضمت ايضا
جوناثا ديفيد لاعب الفرنسي تلعب كندا في
المجموعه السادسه الى جانب المغرب كرواتيا
وبلجيكا وتقص شريط مباريات مواجهه بلجيكا
في الثالث والعشرين من نوفمبر الحاليه على
استاد احمد بن علي المونديالي
واعلن البرتغالي كاروسكيروش قائمه المنتخب
الايراني الذي انضمت 25 لاعب من استعدادا
للمشاركه ايضا في كاس العالم على راس
اللاعبين
نجم بورتو البرتغالي تلعب ايران ضمن
المجموعه الثانيه الى جانب الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه انجلترا ويلز على
المنتخب الايراني في مواجهه انجلترا يستهل
المواجهه امام انجلترا على استاد خليفه
المونديالي في الحادي والعشرين من نوفمبر
الحالي
في انتظار ان يقص المنتخب الفرنسي بطل
العالم شريط حمله الدفاع عن لقب العلمي
بمواجهه الاولى مع استراليا يخشى مشجع
الديك ان يصاب بنزيما ورفاقه بلعنه حامل
لقب كما يبرزه هذا تقريبا
[موسيقى]
سيظل حلم التتويج بلقب كاس العالم الهدف
الاسمر للمنتخبات المشاركه في العرس
العالمي الذي يشارك فيه 32 منتخبه من
بينها ثمانيه فقط احتفلت بملامسه الكاس
خلال 21 بطوله سابقا
لكن الفوز بلقب كان فالا سيئا على عدد من
المنتخبات بدات رحله الدفاع عن لقبها في
البطوله المواليه وهو ما حدث مع منتخب
التانغو عندما قاده النجم دييغو ارماندو
مارادونا للفوز بنسخه عام 86 في المكسيك
مهديا اللقب الثانيه للارجنتين وبعد اربع
سنوات من هذا الانجاز دشن المنتخب
الارجنتيني ومشاركته في مونديال ايطاليا
بخساره تاريخيه امام الكاميرون بهدف فرنسا
وام بيك في مباراه الاولى بالبطوله
ايسكو
بفرنسا عام 98 شاهدت فوزا صاحب الضيافه
المنتخب الفرنسي بقياده النجم زين الدين
زيدان بلقبه التاريخي الاول بانتصار صريح
على البرازيل حامله لقب نسخه عام 94
وبعدها باربع سنوات ودعم منتخب الديه كان
نسخه كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان من الدوري
الاول بعد الهزيمه التاريخيه امام السنغال
في المباراه الافتتاحيه
وتكرر المشهد ذاته مع اسبانيا التي انتظرت
كثيرا للتتويج بباكوره القابها على حساب
هولندا في مونديال 2010 في جنوب افريقيا
بهدف المخدرات اندريس انيستا
[تصفيق]
وبعدها باربع سنوات تلقى الاسبان ضربه
موجعه بخساره قاسيه امامه هولندا تحديدا
بخمسه اهداف لواحد في نسخه البرازيل عام
2014 واكمل لاروخ المسلسل الكارثيه بوداع
البطوله من دورها الاول
النسخه العشرون بالبرازيل شهدت صعود
المانيا لمنصات التتويجي للمره الرابعه في
تاريخها على حساب المنتخب الارجنتيني بهدف
في ماريو جودزا ولكن حامل اللقب لم يجد
الطريقه الامثل في النسخه التي تليها على
الاراضي الروسيه فقد ودع المنشا في
البطوله من دورها الاول بعد ان استهلت
المشوار بخساره امام المكسيك ثم كوريا
الجنوبيه
تاريخيا الصعوبات الكبرى جمه لحاملي لقب
عندما يدافعون عن لقب في النسخه التي سؤال
لمحمد قطب من جديد الصحفي الرياضي محمد
الامر ينطبق ربما على فرنسا بالنظر على
الاقل الصعوبات التي واجهتها في التحضيرات
قبل الوصول الى الدوحه ام لا تتوقعاته
المنتخبات البطل عاده لكن ما قد يبعد هذا
الشبح المنتخب الفرنسي ان هناك تجديد في
التشكيله بعكس منتخبات السابقه منتخب
اسبانيا عندما اتى الى 2014 احتفظت بنفس
تشكيله بعد سنه المنتخب الالماني عندما
ذهب الى 2018 لم يجدد كثيرا ربما الطوره
لتجديد التشكيله لان كونتي وبوجبا ساغيبان
عن تشكيله المنتخب وجوه جديده ظهرت في
العامين الماضيه
هيرنانديز مثلا عوده عثمان ديمبلي الى
مستواه امور ربما تصب في صالح المغامره 11
لاعب من النسخه الاخيره لفرنس بطلت العالم
لن يكونوا حاضرين في الدوله عن تغييرات
جذريه في المنتخب الفرنسي وليس نتحدث عن
تغيرات في التشكيله في دكه البدلاء هناك
همم مجموعه من اللاعبين ستلعب اساسيه منها
اوروليان شاوميني مثلا ادواردو كمانجا
مجموعه اساسيه شابه متعطشه للالقاب ربما
تبعد عن فرنسا هذا الشبح لكن على المنتخب
الفرنسي ان يحضر من المباراه الاولى لانها
دائما ما كانت حجر العثره امام الفرق
البطله في النسخه السابقه
انها تقريبا ستلعب في مجموعه مشابهه
للمجموعه التي لعبت لها في اخر كاس عالم
البيرو بمنتخبته تونس خلاف المنتخب
التونسي لكن بدات ايضا امام استراليا
وتبدا مره اخرى استراليا مباراه اعتاد
ويتفائل الفرنسيون بها لكن دائما المباراه
الاولى في اجواء جديده وبعد اسبوع فقط من
التجمع تكون تحديا كبيرا ربما الخبره في
البطولات تسهم في هذه جانب اخر ايضا من
كاس العالم لاول مره في تاريخ بطولات كاس
العالم تاخذ المنتخبات الافريقيه المنافسه
تحت قياده مدربين محليه
يدخلوا المنتخب المغربي منافسه كاس العالم
قطر 2022 تحت قياده المدرب وليد الرجراجي
الذي تم تعيينه على بعد اسابيع فقط من
انطلاق المونديال وذلك بعد انهاء عقد
المدرب البوسني وحيد خليل وزيتشا اما
المنتخب التونسي فيقوده المدرب جلال
القادري الذي يسعى الى ابراز قيمه المدرب
الوطني يتحقق منتخب تونس نتائج جيده تحت
قياده المدربين محليين خاصه في مونديال
عام 78
ويبحث المنتخب السنغاليه عن التالق في كاس
العالم مع مدربه اليو سيسي الذي قاد
الفريق الى التتويج باول لقب قاري له
عندما فاز بكاس امم افريقيا في فبراير
الماضي اما المنتخب الكاميروني فسيدخل
المنافسه تحت قياده مدافعه السابق ريكو
بيرسونغ الذي تم تعيينه مدربا للكاميرون
في نهايه شهر فبراير الماضي ونجح في تحقيق
التاهل لكاس العالم
و سيدخل المنتخب الغاني المنافسه في
المونديال تحت قياده مدربه اوتو ادو الذي
اكتسب خبره تدريبيه في المانيا منذ موسم
2009 2010 وفي شهر مارس الماضي نجح ايدو
في تحقيق التاهل الى مونديال قطر
افريقيا
ام هو اختيار واختيار استراتيجي محمد اغلب
المدربين الافارقه الذين يتحدث عنهم
التقرير هم المدربون اتوا في حاله طوارئ
في الملحق الفاصل في تصفيات كاس العالم
مثل وتؤدوا الاغاني مثل
الكاميروني وحتى جلال للقدر يمكن اعتباره
جاء لانقاذ المنتخب التونسي في الملحق
امام مالي واما اتوا بعد التاهل لكاس
العالم الوحيد الذي تمتع بالاستمراريه في
السنوات الاخيره كان اليوسيم مدرب المنتخب
ونال كل شيء مع الفريق اصل جاء لي لكن في
اوقات الضروره في اوقات الازمه دائما
بتلجا الفريق الوطني
على خلق المجموعه بشكل سريع وعلى التعامل
الذكي
ربما افضل من المواطن همم
الاعلام ايضا شهدنا فاللوزيتش والصدامه مع
وسائل الاعلام المغربيه كان من العوامل
التي اطاحت بالرجل من تدريب المنتخب
المغربي رغم انه قاد الاسود همم كاس
العالم واتى وليد الركراجي اعتقد ان لغه
الخطاب للاعبين للصحافه لخلق المجموعه في
اوقات ضيقه قبل المونديال وعدم وجود فسحه
كافيه لهذا الوقت للاستعداد هي من ساعدت
المدربين الافارقه على احتلال هذه المكانه
والعلامه الكامله في كاس العالم في اطار
ايضا السعدادات تواصل رابطه الجمهور
العربي همم في الدوحه تحذيرات قبل ايام
انطلاق كاس العالم قطر 2022 كان القطري
فيصل التميمي اطلق هذه المبادره وهي
الاولى من نوعيه في تاريخ المونديال زميلي
حمزه الرازي والتفاصيل في السياق التقرير
الثالث
يلا يلا
حبيبي نشجع بها قلبي يلا يلا
هكذا يستعدون قبل ايامنا على انطلاق بطوله
كاس العالم في قطر هنا يجتمعنا تحت سقف
هذا المجلس الشعبي التقليدي الذي لا يخلو
منه بيت قطري والذي يمثل اهميه رمزيه
كبيره لدى قطر والخليج بصفه عامه طبعا
لدينا شباب يمثلون
المنتخبات العربيه التي سترك في كاس
العالم لدينا ايضا جنسيات عربيه اخرى في
اطار واحد وتحت مظله واحده سنبدا بالحديث
معه صاحب هذه الفكره الدكتور فيصل التميمي
دكتور اذن همم كيف جاءت هذه الفكره جمع
همم مجموعه من الجماهير العربيه من
الجاليه العربيه المقيمه في قطر تحت مظله
واحده وما هي اهداف هذه الرابطه همم نقول
الفكره هذه اصلا انا موجوده في همم داخل
كل عربي كل عربي يحمل هذه المشاعر لكن
احنا التقاطناها من كلمه سمو الامير
الوالد في سنه 2010 عندما قال ان هذه
البطوله هي بطوله العرب وليست بطوله قطر
فمن 12 سنه هذه الجمله الترن في في
الاذهان همم لما جربت بطوله على على
الافتتاح حاولنا ان احنا نحول هذه الجمله
الى واقع فالقينا ان قطر تضم مجموعه كبيره
من الجنسيات ومن ضمنهم 21 جنسيه عربيه
مجرد ما اطلقنا الفكره الحمد لله الكل
تجاوب مثل ما انت شايف قدامك اللي امامك
الان كلهم مدربين احنا عندنا يوم لتدريب
المدربين ويوم اخر لتدريب الجموع انتقل
الى همم اخونا ايوب ايوب هو مشجع سعودي
ايوب همم لو تطلعنا وتطلع الساده
المشاهدين على اخر استعداداتكم همم قبل
همم ايام انطلاق هذا المحفل الكروي الكبير
ان شاء الله تكون همم
يعني
فاحنا قد ما نقدر احنا همم اخواني
المدربين بنحاول قد ما نقدر انه نوصل يعني
نوصل للهجه
واللي تعرفوا المغاربه والتوانسه لهجتهم
مع اللهجه الخليجيه شويه في فرق فهذا اللي
بنحاول قد ما نقدر احنا هنا في الغرفه
المغلقه هذه بنحاول انه همم نوصل نكون جنب
بعض يعني في همم في التداريب يعني انتقل
الى همم ممثل تونس معنا اليوم الاخ همم
سفيان سفيان همم هل هناك اي شكل من اشكال
التنسيق بينكم وبين الجماهير العربيه التي
من المتوقع ان تاتي بكثافه ايضا خلال هذا
الموضوع فم التنسيق ما بيننا ما بين همم
الجماهير خاصه التونسيه اللي موجوده في
تونس من خلال صفحه التواصل الاجتماعي وهم
بيننا مش هما
الاناشيدنهم وريناهم باشا حاجات كيمه
تخراج همم هيك ايه ايه تحكونا الاماكن
اللي مش نجمع فيها اخي نبيل همم الاكيد
الاغاني الكلمات الاهازيج الكل ينتظر ماذا
ستقدمون كيف همم اعددتم لهذه الاهازيج
والاغاني وهل هي من صنعكم 100% اكيد ساكمل
على ما همم ختم به الدكتور فيصل همم هو
همم احنا في دوله عربيه وطبعا حاولنا ما
امكن ان احنا ما نخرج عن القالب بالعربي
فكانت معظم الاغاني تبعنا بالتنسيق طبعا
ما بين شمال افريقيا والخليج حولنا نحافظ
على الهويه العربيه في كل اغانينا وكلها
وليده هذا المكان وليدته ان شاء الله هذا
المونديال سنرى اشياء جديده ان شاء الله
مش معتاد ان احنا نشوفها في في كؤوس
العالم
شكرا لك نبيل شكرا ايوب شكرا سفيان شكرا
دكتور يعطيكم العافيه مره ثانيه على هذه
المبادره وشكرا لجميع الشباب الحاضنين كما
ذكرنا في هذه الجلسه كانت هذه وقفه مع اخر
استعدادات
الجماهير العربيه المقيمه هنا في قطر قبل
ايام من انطلاق كاس العالم حمزه الراضي
الجزيره الدوحه
تعرفنا ايضا مع حمزه على اخر استعدادات
الرابطه الرابطه الجمهور العربي استعدادا
للمونديال مبادره جيده مبادره الاولى من
نوعها في تاريخ نهائيات كاس العالم مميز
في هذه النسخه من كاس العالم ان عامل
الارض والجمهور هو مشترك بين اربعه
منتخبات ليست فقط حكرا على المنتخب القطري
وجود جاليات العربيه المختلفه الجنسيات
هذه المبادره التشجيع الموحد بالنسبه
للمنتخبات العربيه تساعد على ايجاد مناخ
يمكن للمنتخبات العربيه للاستفاده منه في
ايجاد افضليه في المباريات مع الاعتياد
على الاجواء في قطر مع اللاعب في كاس
العرب لعام الماضي كل هذه امور قد تساهم
في نجاح المنتخبات العربيه في هذه البطوله
مبادرات من هذا النوع سيكون لها اثر كبير
في همم طريقه تشجيع في نوعيه الاجواء في
المباريات كاس العالم